bébé n'y va pas
oh mon dieu
nous sommes tous très heureux d'être heureux tôt
j'imagine que ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
docteur c'est Lee weathers de l'entreprise je
cherche juste des informations sur
Morgan Morgan était une troisième tentative de
notre petit  percée c'est la prochaine
étape de l'évolution
c'est bio-conçu avec de l'ADN synthétique
en un mois marcher et parler en
six mois nous avons dépassé nos
attentes les plus folles j'aimerais discuter de l'
incident si ça va
elle a fait une crise il y avait de la joie dans son
cœur avant que nous bousculions  elle est de retour dans cette
boîte tu te sens un peu triste Morgan
oui est-ce que tu aimes ça ici oui chérie
j'aime ça j'aime mes amis penses-tu
qu'ils te traitent comme un ami je veux dire tu
penses que c'est normal que des amis
s'enferment  dans des cages que feriez-vous si
je vous recommandais de ne pas être
autorisé à quitter cette pièce euh si je
vous recommandais de déterminer si nécessaire nous
devrions mettre fin à cette réponse moi
ce que vous faites
où Morgan
initie le verrouillage quoi  tu ne
comprends pas Morgan évolue toujours les
gens de cette maison sont en danger il
faut y mettre fin sept six pour avoir
peur cinq quatre
je commence à me sentir moi même